are you ready to go to mommy's doctor
yeah
honestly you're days away
a couple of days away
[Music]
kylie jenner is gearing up for baby
number two and the source is filling e.t
in on everything happening in the
cosmetics queen's world
[Music]
our source says quote she feels like she
was born to be a mom and can't wait to
start another chapter of her life with
stormi and travis by her side the source
adds that travis has been doting on the
reality star and hardly leaves her side
quote their relationship is in a
beautiful space and they are more in
love than ever and so incredibly excited
about the future
[Music]
but the thing they're most excited about
giving their three-year-old daughter
stormi a sibling quote stormy is over
the moon ecstatic travis and kylie are
trying to include stormy bit by bit and
doing things like involving her in what
the nursery will look like they are
making sure she knows how loved she is
and preparing her to be a big sister by
keeping her very engaged
[Music]
as for kylie's famous fam the source
says they are her biggest cheerleaders
and supporters quote her family is so
excited especially because they all love
travis they are also offering to help
wherever and whenever especially mom
kris jenner
[Music]
to our source kylie knows her hands are
going to be even fuller when baby number
two arrives so she is welcoming any
advice especially from her mom and
sisters kim and courtney the family
grows and it's getting bigger all the
time and yeah it's really fun to see the
the babies have babies the soar says
that the fam is already setting up play
dates for stormy with her cousins to
allow kylie some private time when she
needs it they bounce around to all their
aunties you know into my house and it's
it's good of course this time around
kylie is in keeping her pregnancy
journey under wraps she didn't confirm
her pregnancy with stormy until after
giving birth so i'm 34 weeks today
only about a month left kylie confirmed
reports she was expecting with a special
vlog and our source says she wanted to
share the happy news on her own terms
kylie knew the news of her pregnancy was
going to come out eventually she is
super excited but is also looking for
some privacy and wants to share special
moments and this wonderful new beginning
with her family and closest friends the
soon to be mom of two recently showed
off her baby bump stepping out wearing a
white leather mini dress and coat
our source says kylie wants to pour all
of her energy into her body and the
wonderful new being that she is creating
[Music]
true